Why is Mustard is Yellow?
A common misconception is that yellow mustard
(the kind you put on your hot dog) is yellow
because of the mustard seed.
This is not true.
The mustard seed is a dullish gray, brown
color.
The striking, bold yellow color actually comes
from the rootstock of a plant called turmeric.
Turmeric, native to the rainy humid tropical
forests of South Asia, has been used as a
natural food dye for centuries.
The turmeric plant is harvested annually for
its rhizome, or rootstock.
The rhizome is boiled, dried out, and ground
into a powder.
This powder is then mixed with mustard seed
powder, vinegar, water, salt, and voila, you
got yourself traditional yellow mustard!
Turmeric is also a common ingredient in many
South Asian and Indian dishes.
It provides an earthy, slightly bitter taste
that complements many curries.
In addition, it isn’t just the rhizome powder
that is used for cooking, but the whole plant.
The leaves of the turmeric plant are used
in many Indonesian recipes due to the plentifulness
of the plant in the region and the sharp flavor
of the leaves.
Throughout the generations of living off of
the land in the region, people have discovered
that turmeric possesses many medicinal qualities.
Traditionally, it has been used an anti-inflammatory,
antiseptic, and a guard against liver damage.
In fact, the American Cancer Society has officially
stated that curcumin, the active ingredient
in turmeric, is an antioxidant and has shown
in preliminary studies to kill cancer cells
in lab samples.
Plus, it has been found to reduce the growth
of several different forms of cancer cells
and tumors in lab animals.
The United States Institute of Health rated
turmeric as “possibly effective” for Osteoarthritis
and upset stomach, with research still pending.
Turmeric began to make its way west during
the 12th and 13th centuries.
In medieval England, turmeric was often called
“Indian saffron” since it was often used
as a cheaper alternative to the much more
pricey saffron.
In 1280, Marco Polo wrote in his memoirs that
turmeric was a vegetable “with the properties
of saffron, though it is not really saffron”.
In the 18th century, turmeric was beginning
to be grown in Caribbean countries, where
the climate was similar to South Asia.
Jamaica became a big grower of turmeric and
to this day, rhizome powder is still used
in Jamaican cuisine.
Getting back to the mustard of it all, mustard
itself dates back to the ever-enterprising
Romans.
They would combine the seeds with unfermented
grape juice to create what they called “burning
juice”, or mustum ardens in Latin (hence
our now familiar English word “mustard”.)
The popularity of mustard grew in Rome and
swept into their conquered territories.
In the Burgundy region of France, most famous
for its wines, a little town called Dijon
embraced mustard and began making its own
variety, substituting the unfermented grape
juice with vinegar.
To this day, Dijon, France is still known
as the mustard capital of the world for its
unique and sharp tasting Dijon mustard.
Yellow mustard didn’t come along until the
turn of the 20th century.
In 1884, two brothers by the name of Robert
and George French bought a flourmill in Rochester,
New York after their previous flourmill upstate
burned down.
They named the mill the R.T.
French Company.
When Robert passed away, George’s other
brother, Francis, came aboard to help the
family business.
In 1904, George began experimenting with “creamy
salad mustard”.
He added turmeric to the traditional recipe
for added presentation and color.
Yellow mustard premiered at the St. Louis
World’s Fair in 1904 as a condiment to put
on hot dogs to great fanfare.
The rest, as it were, is mustard history.